it keeps falling to go it's gonna go
isn't it let's get a go here a tasty we
make a lot of layered food great cakes
croquembouche a hundred layer lasagna
I've been challenged by my coworker to
stack as many pancakes as I possibly can
there are only two rules the first rule
is it can only be pancakes stacked one
on top of the other and the second rule
is I cannot use any support I don't know
why I agreed to do this okay I'm
thinking that the base should be like
the widest pancake so we get like the
most the sturdiest miss so it's gonna be
a bunch of pancakes and then it gets
more narrow until we put just like a
babe you can kick at the top and it's
kind of a pyramid maybe not exactly a
pyramid I think I just got to get
started and we'll see what happens so it
made a lot of batter and I've got two
burners that are gonna be going at the
same time to maximize efficiency okay so
you might be like Kati that's a lot of
pancakes what are you gonna do with all
that are you gonna throw it in the trash
no I'm gonna give it to my fellow
coworkers I'm going for thinner pancakes
because I think we'll have less oka a
bulge in the center of the pancake well
have it like a little bit more
consistently flat and that bulge over
time I feel like we'll build up and
create like unsteadiness what oh no no
no no no first pancake first hand cake
it's like dare I add one more burner
into the mix it's that crazy okay we got
three burners people I'm gonna get
started I'm feeling good so maybe I
don't regret this maybe I'm gonna feel
so good at the end of this so
accomplished okay so I have made a lot
of pancakes
I think the count is 84 right now I'm
gonna now transition to smaller pans as
per my drawing I can see the light we're
close we're close it's going very slowly
okay I just realized that I have three
burgers and I could just get another pan
cuz we have like 500 of them so
Ron the very last one the very last one
I think for this last one I should try
to flip it like the professionals you
know like that it's just a just an
upward motion and you just get it going
I don't think this bodes well for the
stacking part of this competition I've
made all the pancakes I can possibly
make today it took a really long time I
think there's about a hundred and three
now all that there's left to do is stack
so I'm ready I'm gonna get started I
[Music]
feel like I'm a golfer trying to line up
a putt right now okay I'm feeling good
about this these pancakes have seen
better days
like this guy better to have him in the
pack I'm not at all alright hey not bad
it's very it's getting very jiggly can I
get on the stool I'm on a stool now cuz
that's where we are which is exciting
but also terrifying
ah haha I see a weakness over here on
the Left I haven't been like stressed
for anything like this in my whole life
not even finals every time I put one on
it just feels a little bit weaker I
haven't realized what I didn't do I was
like I'm gonna have a really strong base
but I made so many middle like in
between ones I'm gonna stop with the
middle men then I'm gonna go to my bit
smaller guys a little bit more stable I
think is that a mistake we're committed
now so we're going it's leaning a lot to
the left like okay okay I've got to
bring it towards myself okay
want to go it's gonna go it's a bit it's
gonna go now can I touch it can i
address let me just just I'm a little
twisty I didn't make enough big ones I
can just go to his own place
[Music]
just shift a lot of pancakes I'm
touching sorry is it helping no can you
tell from the front I'm making it worse
I'm making it worse
with every turn okay whoo-hoo every
pancakes a victory no no no no stop it
pancakes this is this is horrifying
that's just what nightmares are made of
maybe I should just go for some tiny
ones that are less weight just for
height yeah
little hat I feel like we maybe cuts
through the end stuff like this stick
can hold I don't know if I could do
anything to stop it from Levine's truth
switching paint paint this is the end of
the road for us the structure has been
compromised he's gonna give away right
towards me right he's coming down he's
coming what do I do
do I just let him go or do I try to exit
war do we just part ways here yes maybe
I don't know if it's gonna stand without
me touching that I don't think I can
stack anymore with this say structurally
sound but I'm just gonna keep stacking
and see how many more we can get on till
it falls over here goes nothing oh my
gosh it's already alright okay well 58
was the backs
hi I'm sweating and this was stressful
cuz that's a lot of pancakes I got 58 I
feel proud of that I'd like to see Rea
do better I'm just kidding ahahaha I'm
gonna go share these with all my
co-workers we're all gonna have a big
breakfast right now oh my gosh that's
ah I want you to get it but I also don't
it's a lot of mixed feelings no all
right okay wait
all right it was like that was like I'm
30
[Music]